how's the gum resumes ah welcome back to
the walking dead let's keep playing baby
make me a king wait there right let's
find something else shall we shall we
little clammy yeah but I don't see
anything else like I can do and I can't
really oh here we go you can break the
alarm or whatever if the battery is
still in working which is or made the
horn yet a horn is that someone
high-fiving that cat really that's not
enough but we need to keep it going
somehow maybe key we could use this
shard that she had before right I'll
talk to her about it what am I looking
for see if you can find something to
distract them what are you doing then
God
what are you thinking
if we lean him on the horn it'll keep
honking and draw the walkers Jeanne is
fine like moths to a flame
give me a hand miss the puzzles to be
honest wolf among us didn't have that
many I can't remember at least
that's adorable we find a new friend oh
my god it's pure deep I get em now now's
your time to go it's time to bounce come
on you can take that batch out oh watch
out Clem neat and it goes by nice
bandana brah come on
what who took away this we gotta move it
particularly but but they were such good
friends
Kakadu something else um all right
brofist or how about breakfast breakfast
dad don't [ __ ] push me don't [ __ ]
push Glenn oh he blocked this hurry and
that's it what that look clam oh thank
god Nick find you he made a run for it
looking for help I shouldn't tell him
now I'm outside look he was out there
but we took care of him you know
when I hurt y'all banging through the
door
I thought the walkers come and take
what's left of us we gotta get moving
Oh second that I would have left already
but I got Sarah here I don't know what
to do about her what's the matter she's
following him and she's a Sammy there
was a duck there beautiful art in this
house who ever lived there it was great
see she gone Loco Sarah come on we have
to go now I guess Carver messed me up
pretty good back there I don't know it's
just after Carlos she just lost it
I chased her for I don't know how long
and then while she saw this mobile home
made a beeline hi for I'm just glad
y'all are here uh-oh that's not good yet
what are we gonna do about her we got to
do something maybe she'll listen to me
yeah it's been so [ __ ] nice to her
this better come to useful listen
they're gonna tear this place open
pretty soon we can't stay so we got to
get her up or we got it come on talk to
her Clinique Lou I've been trying I've
been trying for hours I can barely get
her to look at me
clam come on climb museum use your
cuteness magic Clem use cloak cute it's
super effective
some people you just can't help okay
I've seen it before you helped me when
we first met now I want to help you
it's marking maybe it seems like you're
all alone right now but you're not more
cuteness there we go
Jane and me we came here because of you
all of us in the group we're your family
now we're surrounded what what about the
skylight oh we got clam there's no time
clam listen Jane might be right when
everything started I met my friend Lee
he tried to help me find my parents he
protected me more than anyone else in my
whole life he died to keep me safe
I was so scared
but you're still here because he taught
me to be strong even when I'm scared
because he wanted me to live and your
dad protected you because he wanted you
to live you would still want that
my ribs we're gonna need something to
stand on
Luke get over here help me hold this
plan see what you can find once again
it's up to clam it's not big enough the
fridge forget it nothing ain't budging
find something else well you're kind of
holding it can we use that yeah that
would work
how strong can the Sam is be I mean come
on
on three I don't have any man soul BAM
they badass they really bad yes nice
picture there love the Ducks oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
hopefully minecraft justice come on I'm
never clicked o'clock and until come out
oh she's fogged isn't she yeah she's
dead
[Applause]
there was one on the floor where did it
go Luke you first we need you up top
go look come on okay come on Glenn Sarah
we have to go are you listening now
Clementine
she doesn't want to go you can't make
her please let there be an option to
bitch-slap come on dying like this is
stupid you can't favor Glenn we have to
go
believe me I know about this hurry up
slap that batch move
Clementine crabber I swear to God if she
dies because of you oh thank god
Oh minecraft we gotta go come on sorry I
called her a [ __ ] but seriously
seriously oh thank god there was a slap
option thank God for slap options man
this place situation are we there yet
we're not far it's [ __ ] look Sarah you
can get through this we both will but
I'm not okay
just try can you do that she just needs
a little time Clem leave her be for a
bit I bet that slap reminded her of her
dad when he slapped her that's horrible
I'm so sorry I got this the way she is
she's gonna cause problems it's gonna be
pretty attack know more about what
happened in there when we went in there
you were ready to help but then yeah
what changed yeah look I just I'd seen
that kind of thing before I just didn't
want to stick around for the bitter end
sorry I I don't mean to sound harsh it's
just the way things are
does that mean you'd turn on me if I was
hurt or something no I mean Clem I
wouldn't have to and just because you
got her out of there today doesn't mean
you saved her trust me that's [ __ ]
horrible save Jamie - but she gave up
I just I can't believe it as soon as you
guys said go I was the first one up on
the room like I had already made up my
mind about what Luke you can't let it
eat away at you
well I can't forget it I dragged my
sister across four states and every
morning she'd say she wasn't getting up
so I'd convince her
or push her goddamn carrier if I had to
until this time walkers cornered us
forced us up to the roof and when they
kept coming I couldn't make her jump
couldn't throw her so I tried something
else I told her she could have what she
wanted and I left her there oh nice
jump to the next building over by myself
you left your sister Jane I'm really
sorry what else can you say yeah
Benedict you fight they don't know for a
long time but I finally realized that
I'd put her on a forced march through
hell what she really wanted was for me
to let her go well it's not for everyone
Jane no regard for her own safety or
ours Sara and Jamie aren't the same
person we don't know she'll end up like
that people don't change
come on let's get back to your friends
that's some night that leaves men
[ __ ] load those leaves probably my
favorite leaves over a long time I like
that statue it's pretty better yes
whatever they exist for reals that'd be
cool you found them man you didn't do
[ __ ] ya little amaze myself tell you the
truth weren't for Clement Jane well I
don't know what would have happened
Sarah
how you doing I'm okay sweetie
whenever you're ready I'm just glad
you're here wait where's Nick I'll
Rebecca how about we yeah and go for a
walk for a minute let's just give him
some space I have something I need to
talk to you about Oh yada yada that sign
looks unlike Arkadiy to sugarcoat this
that baby's coming even faster than
Rebecca's letting on but I was hoping
you might know does loop know anything
about babies
has he I don't know mentioned Carlos
teaching him anything Kenny had a family
he could help where is he
did he just take off I was in the tent
what the great place was in there after
you left I said he needed a minute by
himself
I didn't seen him since I don't think
he's doing well I've seen him like this
before that's why I was thinking you
could talk to him I think if it's just
you someone he knows well you might be
able to get through to him and I
wouldn't ask you to do it if it weren't
for the baby I'll do it because I might
if I can claim him in town that needs to
be like a badass rap song about
Clementine being badass because she's
badass just saying she's the one who
pulls [ __ ] together that when everyone
else is just being big it's he and stuff
do you bros remember in season through
the episode through ye like Epis season
1 that girl that shot
Carly what was her name again what if
she comes back I just realized she could
come back I wouldn't like that because
she never did
I wanted to check on you make sure
you're okay
you know what it feels like to get
beaten almost to death peaceful
it feels peaceful um it was like I was
floating away watching the whole thing
happened to me and then I woke up again
and nothing's changed I'm still taking a
beating
every day duck kochia Sarita no peace no
rest the punches just keep coming
I'll have a hell could Carver have just
finished me off
obviously I ain't helping anyone by
being here that's not true you help me
all the time
I need you I've seen you take care of
yourself more than any three adults put
together thinking boy huh thanks for
saying that now I don't worry yourself
about this it's nothing
hadn't kill me yet anyway
it looks like it must hurt well oh [ __ ]
does that mean what I think it does what
are we supposed to do
go Kenny now you have I believe at you
we go and deliver the baby and it's
gonna be mad a beautiful and I'm gonna
get the hot towels cuz that that's what
I do still don't know what you do with
it pod talents are you okay how does it
feel it feels wet okay I would feel they
waited bacon Rebecca's water broke hmm
oh Christ
we should I don't know what we should do
oh [ __ ] that means the baby's coming
right Kenny
thank God I think the baby's coming what
do we do
all right all right give me a second
no way can rebecca trample like this
he's right she's gonna make a lot of
noise they'll be able to smell her too
what should we do first Kenny Kenny come
on you gotta focus yes focus right right
sorry clean water for one thing in
blankets hot Alice we gotta get out of
this damn call to that map shows a
couple of buildings nearby maybe one of
them could do the trick
yeah cuz buildings are all is so [ __ ]
safe
the museum seems like it could be a good
start I'll go good idea Mike
think you could go with her do a thing
I'll check the building by the river
okay then Kenny you uh stick with
Rebecca and I will check the perimeter
for walkers Sarah Sarah you just stay
here with Rebecca and Kenny okay Clem
I know it must have been hard but thank
you for talking to Kenny it's what I do
I'd love for you to give me a Mac a hand
looking at the museum but I was thinking
how do we know Janey just gonna take off
maybe should go with her make sure she
comes back what do you mean by that
what if son doesn't seem to like being
around people much and she volunteered
to head off awful fans I guess it could
be nothing she's helped us so far yeah
no you're right maybe it's nothing just
something to think about
okay we're looking for warm blankets
clean water disinfecting that all sound
right maybe I should go with Jane better
hurry and catch up there
all right everyone you know what to do
let's be fast and let's be careful
I'm so excited for this I'm so freakin
excited for this oh that looks like a
good balding that looks pretty too I
like it it's very nice very nice and dad
what are we having here you have a bench
that we can talk to a low bench thank
you we have a bench let's talk to it
alright it's gonna take about three and
a half years there we go
it's my lucky day what who's that
Oh thought it was him oh hey
what are you doing what are you doing
getting lost in thought not the safest
habit to have these days
well it's sometimes good to have someone
watching your back there you go
so come on partner let's go check out
that deck I like the height I like that
we can change they're kind of you know I
feel like we are influencing her if
we're better I hope so
partner don't let it get to your head
let's go
let's kill have sex kill I hope this
place is what we're looking for
it's only one way to find out use a
break
what's that left flag what does that
mean
check us down a state still locked which
means that hopefully no one's gotten to
whatever was locked in there in the
first place who knows what could be in
there
that could be a place for Rebecca to
have the baby yeah that's what I was
thinking great minds think a duck mmm
maybe I can pick the lock the nail file
versatility is not overrated
I'd be impressed you know wouldn't hurt
to try a heavier hand to something see
if you can find something bigger we
might need a bus or mechanism
okay I'll just use this [ __ ] cannon
is that still work that would be amazing
check the muzzle Napoleon boom they fill
them with some men so they're safe wow
what a bummer my buddy gonna dip right
we'd had this poster and we have this
trashcan I don't think any of those is
gonna work I'll check a little further
in fact I can't [ __ ] I'm still hoping
for Sammy baby hashtags am they baby
she's gonna read about the Civil War
this is like a Civil War Reenactment
site I know they have them and you would
say I will see them in movies so that's
how I know that's how I know most of the
things from you will say like so I guess
their flag is from the North States
that's probably what it is I have that
it's a map
there's some buildings across the river
I think I can see a church the nearest
river crossing is miles up Rebecca
wouldn't make it in her condition who
the [ __ ] is that Jane there's someone
coming toward us
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's coming his way
is that a boom Bob knows if he has
friends nearby why is he coming up here
no idea it looks like he's not moving
real fast see what he's up to
come on he's nice some stranger sneaking
around so close to the others we've got
enough on our plates with a baby coming
maybe I can try talking to him good call
Shh hide now she should hide and Clem
should talk to her him well maybe he'll
unlock the log yeah that'll about does
it
Oh what is he doing he's trying to hide
the bag no there will be some weird
moral choice he looks nice I'll talk to
him I'm just a kid
please don't hurt me put the gun down do
you understand me yes I'm horrible I'm
going to go shoot don't I don't want to
shoot anyone especially my name Koh good
little girl you don't have to shoot
anyone just put the gun down
it's not necessary
put the bag down no Glenn make sure he
doesn't have any other weapons in there
I wouldn't do is it close to him he
could like uppercut her face with a kick
that doesn't work no I have no more guns
I swear we just need to make anything
Wow
that's a serious - Ahmed's no no no take
whatever you want but don't take the
medicine it's for my sister my older
sister she's sick
the pain makes her cry and that makes
those things come please dismiss all she
has is it just you and your sister she
eats a lot of [ __ ] medicine I have
many friends in the woods sister or not
we could really use that stuff we've got
people who are suffering who need this
medicine Luke still a wreck after
Carver's Kenny's a mess Rebecca's in
pain oh look at all of it Clementine we
need this of suffering just as much as
yours you are not special I believe at
you you're not taking them I'm not
robbing anybody just let him go yeah
Mele wouldn't do that push it thank you
Clementine thank you
don't don't know what are you doing
[Music]
don't you ever come around here again
I don't care if you do have some sick
sister the next time I see you you won't
just be walking away go
how the [ __ ] he walk alone with that
leg threatening some stupid kid
we should go get everyone else yeah
go get the others we did this place
opened then we need to get moved in ASAP
I think we did the right thing
remember in the first episode where we
saw the car and we chose not to steal it
yeah we baited a niche
clam clam hey any luck with that
observation dick
I was just checking on Rebecca Kenny
they said they hadn't heard from you in
a while I don't guess there'd be much
but Jane seems pretty resourceful
shouldn't you be with Rebecca no now
Kenny's way more help with your back of
the NACA B I'm really making sure we
keep track of where everyone is is Jane
still up there now yeah she's trying to
get the gift shop opened no I can't
figure her out
and she really lays it on the line but
at the same time she doesn't show you
anything they can't I like her she's
honest and she knows what she's doing
yep that's more than I can save her son
Jane seems like the kind of person who
gets tempered by hardship you know but
when I look at Kenny now he just he
seems broken broken people get reckless
I know you got a history with him look I
think he's a good guy at least started
as a good guy you're wrong
Kenny stronger than anyone he tries to
protect us
I don't know Clem I know he's your
friend and all but what Kenny did to
Carver
it sounded like he beat right through
the corpse and into the floor is that
where we are now
and what would you have done if it was
you well I don't know really I don't
I just think less probably
not a no main I need to tell the others
about the deck yeah
good I will see you back there
can't wait for the same babes that they
be Bobby there should be a song called
on zabi I was a bee
I was a bee I want to have your zombie
baby baby all right they I get Indian it
be their name what are you getting you
home Annie thank you for leaving Leigh
yeah the brofist for you bro feeis